a device a device every oh hello there
oh I'm sorry it's just such a lovely day
birds chirping Attorney General William
bar has released the Muller report with
relatively few redactions and he gave a
highly entertaining press conference
this morning at about 6:30 a.m. Pacific
we will go through the good the bad and
the ugly of all of the relevant sections
of the report what it means for
president Trump what it means for the
media what it means for 2020 I'm Michael
Knowles and this is the Michael Knowles
show
[Music]
I had a device in my head because
apparently that's what was being played
at the White House this morning
just a beautiful sunshine day because
obviously the White House is presenting
this report as full aid exonerating
president Trump and totally condemning
the media and the Democrats who have
been pushing this story for two years
there's good stuff in the report there's
bad stuff in the report there's stuff in
the report that doesn't reflect well on
President Trump but all in all they are
right all in all this is a really really
good day for president Trump we will get
into why that is but first you know
about movement you know how much I love
the movement it is very important too
that men wear timepieces I always loved
timepieces I always loved wristwatches
and movement is fabulous my personal
favorite is the revolver collection the
revolver collection in particular mine
is Atlas and it's this super sleek
looking watch it has a retro feel it's
got a nice domed crystal but it's also
modern so I've gotten more compliments
on this watch and I've gotten on any
other complement or any other watch I've
had in my life they're fabulous and they
just released their first ever automatic
watch the arc automatic it is super cool
movement if you are listening I really
want one of these watches they are
really really great they look really
sleek and obviously they have this cool
complication in them the the Rhys
collection is really nice it's just this
I don't know it's this mixture of the
1960s and the future I guess that's the
only way to describe it they're all
about looking good while keeping it
simple they don't tell you how many
steps you've taken they don't blow your
wrist up with text messages I hate that
stuff I want a watch that tells me the
time in an elegant way men should wear
timepieces they're just really really
nice it's a cool entrepreneur story it's
these college dropouts they drop out of
college and now they've sold a million
and a half watches in over 160 countries
they start at just 95 bucks in a
department store that cost 4 or 500
bucks but it's a clean design it's
minimal really quality you can get 15%
off today with free shipping and free
returns you can do that by going to
movement comm MVM t.com slash Knowles
can or wle
they're launching new styles on their
site all the time check out the latest
at MVM t.com slash Knowles ko wles
and join the movement anything in the
news today I guess so I guess there is
they were playing the song Edelweiss at
the White House and Maggie Haberman of
the Democrat Party I mean of the media I
mean of the New York Times or whatever
she writes for she said they were
playing Edelweiss do they know what that
song means she's trying to call Trump
and not see because Adel Vice comes from
The Sound of Music what she forgets is
that it was sung by people opposing the
Nazis in the sound of music that
exemplifies how the media have gotten
this story wrong from the very beginning
and that is why the day began before
they released the redacted report the
day began with Attorney General William
Barre giving a press conference on the
report why they're releasing the report
why certain parts of the report have
been redacted and taking reporters
questions the main takeaway here the
main takeaway from this whole press
conference is that Attorney General
William Barr has an IQ at least twice
that of every reporter in that room
combined it was dizzying and distressing
to look at how stupid the reporters came
off and how well William Barr came off
this guy is no joke the media are now
trying to present him as some sort of
hack private lawyer for President
trumpet can't do that with William Barr
William Barr was the Attorney General in
1991 William Barr has been around a long
time he's a very smart guy he's very
serious guy he's a very well-respected
guy that really came through in this
press conference he actually reminded me
a lot of Antonin Scalia the way that he
would listen to questions the way he
could identify instantly where these
reporters were going and the way he just
clobbered them with the answer so the
left has been going after William Bar
for a couple of weeks now the question
that is to be asked is is the summary
that William Barr gave of the Muller
report a fair assessment
or an unfair assessment is the
assessment that he gave basically
correct when he released his four-page
report a couple weeks ago or is he
covering up and spinning and trying to
fix the media for Donald Trump here is
attorney general bars main takeaway
counsel found no evidence that any
American including anyone associated
with the Trump campaign conspired or
coordinated with the Russian government
or the IRA in this illegal scheme indeed
as the report states quote the
investigation did not identify evidence
that any US person knowingly or
intentionally coordinated with the IRAs
interference operation unquote put
another way the Special Counsel found no
collusion by any Americans in IRAs
illegal activities no collusion he makes
a point of simplifying this for people
the Special Counsel found no collusion
now we've known this for a while I think
even the sophisticated Democrats in the
media have known there's no collusion
Van Jones a very sophisticated
left-winger said a year ago over a year
ago the Russia thing is a nothing burger
so then the question comes down to was
there obstruction so there's no
collusion it's not as though President
Trump was working with Vladimir Putin to
fix the 2016 election but even though
there was no collusion was there
obstruction so once the Muller
investigation began did President Trump
try to obstruct the investigation now
it's a perfectly legitimate question to
ask how can you obstruct an
investigation when there's no underlying
crime if I haven't committed a crime how
can I be said to try to obstruct an
investigation into a crime that never
happened that's a that's a fair question
arguments on both sides which we'll get
to in a second here but did President
Trump behave in some crooked way to fix
this investigation to fix the
conclusions here to work with bar to
work with Muller to work with any of
these things did he obstruct justice
now the mainstream
are furious today and Democrats are
furious because William Bar and the DOJ
briefed the White House on the report so
this is now their big takeaway and
they're saying this is the evidence of
some corruption here in the Trump
administration in the DOJ because the
Attorney General briefed the president's
team before releasing it to Congress and
before giving this press conference and
before releasing it to the press
William Bar clears up this question
which all of the news media have been
going on and prattling on about four
hours Chuck Todd said it was evidence
that Trump colluded with the Attorney
General William Bar gives the very
simple explanation of why the White
House was briefed on this report
following my March 29th letter the
office of the White House Counsel
requested the opportunity to review the
redacted version of the report in order
to advise the President on the potential
invocation of privilege which is
consistent with long-standing practice
following that review the president
confirmed that in the interest of
transparency and full disclosure to the
American people he would not assert
privilege over the special counsels
report accordingly the public report I
am releasing today contains redactions
only for the four categories that I
previously outlined and no material has
been redacted based on executive
privilege very important that he makes
this point because they say will you
brief to the White House they're gonna
cook this up they're gonna interfere
with its release no he says the
president is fully within his rights to
exercise executive privilege and
determine what goes out what doesn't go
out now he's fully within his rights to
do that and therefore he has to see or
the I suppose his team has to see the
redacted version of the report before it
goes out so just definitionally he's got
to see it he William Barr sends it over
to them and they do not make any
additional redactions so the White House
has not interfered in this report
the White House being briefed on this
did not result in any additional
redactions any changes to the report
whatsoever now the thing to remember
here the thing you've got to always keep
in mind is that the mainstream media are
not that intelligent I don't even mean
this just to beat up on the media but
they're just not that intelligent the
reason you sometimes think they're very
intelligent is because they wear suits
and they have nice ties and they speak
really seriously into a camera they're
not they're not really that smart and
you see this in the exchanges that the
reporters are having with William Barse
so this one reporter goes on for
probably a whole minute trying to
basically make the case that bar has
acted improperly and that this is a
crooked press conference and she's
trying to go after him obviously
she can't stand President Trump and just
look at how swiftly William bar takes
her down listen to this and here you
have remarks that are quite generous to
the president including acknowledging
his feelings his emotion what do you say
to people on both sides of the aisle
we're concerned that you were trying to
protect the president actually the
statements about his is his sincere
beliefs are recognized in the report
that there was substantial evidence for
that so I'm not sure what your basis is
for saying that I am being generous to
the president another president for one
present it is an accurate description
isn't it just absolutely devastating
well you're being really really generous
to the president how am i doing that
okay well you you're saying this is
unprecedented
is it precedented No then I guess it's
unprecedented isn't it yeah but but I
don't like you really there are a lot of
exchanges that go on in this press
conference just like that it basically
sums up the forces of reality the people
who are analyzing this document and the
media who have cooked up a narrative for
two years you are watching them there
if collapse in real time it is
extraordinarily enjoyable and we haven't
even gotten to the report yet before we
get to that first rings mission is to
make neighborhoods safer you might
already know about their smart video
doorbells and cameras that protect
millions of people everywhere ring helps
you stay connected to your home anywhere
in the world so if there's a package
delivery or surprise visitor you will
get an alert and be able to see hear and
speak to them all from your phone that's
thanks to the HD video and two-way audio
features unring devices J hey the senior
producer of this show was sleeping at
home the other night everybody at Dailey
wire has ring and he gets this knock on
his door rings the doorbell he looks at
it's these two drug addled maniacs like
3:00 in the morning you say hey can we
can we come in and use your phone he
says no I don't think so now J hey could
have been in his bedroom which he was he
could have been at the office he could
have been on a beach somewhere because
you get to talk to these people wherever
you are eventually obviously they scram
because they don't want to they don't
want to break into a house where some
guy is already talking to them knows
exactly what they're trying to do it
just makes you feel safer I love it I
makes me feel safer I recommend it to
all my friends I've given it to many of
my friends as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion activated floodlight
camera the starter kit has everything
you need to start building a ring of
security around your home just go to
ring.com slash Knowles that is ring comm
slash Knowles they're very angry that
William bar is handily explaining all of
the totally proper procedure that's
going on here with the release of this
report so they pinned their hopes on
Muller the use all the t-shirts
it's Muller time the left has been
building up Bob Muller for a long time
now and so one reporter asks why is Bob
Muller not here giving this press
conference and William bar clears up
this very important point there's a lot
of public interest in the absence of the
special counsel and members of his team
was he invited to join him up on the
podium why is he not here
his report obviously that your topic on
today cuz I support he did for me as the
Attorney General he is required under
the regulation to provide me with a
confidential report I'm here to discuss
my response to that report and my
decision entirely discretionary to make
it public since these reports are not
supposed to be made public boom perfect
answer what the media have been trying
to do is to establish this very dubious
legal idea that the special counsel is
above everybody else this is the problem
with the special counsel why on earth is
some random lawyer who gets picked
suddenly the most powerful person on the
face of the earth more powerful than the
President of the United States the media
have been trying to build this up
because they don't like that Donald
Trump was elected they don't like that
Donald Trump's appointees are now
running the government so that reporter
says look this is Bob Muller's report
how come Bob Muller is not here and
Attorney General William bar says no no
that's my report it's not his report
it's my report he did it for me because
I am the Attorney General and some
randomly appointed special counsel is
not allowed to be the most important
political figure on the face of the
earth now this this brings up another
question too because there is some
discrepancy between the Muller report
and the way that Attorney General
William Bar and Deputy Attorney General
rod Rosenstein are talking about it
which we'll get to in one second there's
a last-gasp though the last gasp of
these reporters who really really want
to convince everybody that this is just
a bunch of spin this is a bunch of PR
this is a show they actually just ask
this to bar straight out and bargains
them a straight answer
propriety for you to come out in sort of
what appears cities are spitting they're
important for public use if I forget the
history
no no no no that's what he's saying
so there's there's it's not improper
it's obviously proper if he hadn't given
this press conference the left would be
screaming that he hadn't given this
press conference so now let's get to the
report itself the reason I open up with
this is because there isn't very much
new in the report I haven't made it
through all 400 pages yet or 380 pages
or whatever it is I've probably gotten
for about a hundred pages you really
don't need to read the whole thing
because only certain sections of it are
relevant to these questions at hand
did the president commit a crime did the
president obstruct justice did senior
members of his campaign obstruct justice
so you actually can get basically all
the information you need with about 100
pages of it and the main takeaway here
is that we don't really learn anything
new we don't learn anything new that we
didn't already know about president
Trump or that we didn't already strongly
suspect that he was doing
we knew that President Trump didn't like
the special counsel we knew the
president Trump wanted to shut down the
special counsel we knew that President
Trump wasn't as familiar as lifelong
politicians with the way that government
works we know that he behaved like a
real estate developer in New York rather
than as a lifelong politician we knew
all of these things I think the Muller
report tells us more about the Muller
investigation then it tells us about
president Trump's conduct anybody out
there who's telling you this is a
bombshell this is explosive this is
amazing ask that person what new
conclusion can they reach what's the new
what's the news all of the fake news all
of the mainstream media cable news
they're trying to spin this as some
shocking development ask them to
pinpoint exactly what is new here I'll
tell you the one point that they bring
up just I just pulled it up from the
report itself the one point that a lot
of them dishonestly bring up is they say
this is from from the special counsels
report
according to notes written by hunt when
sessions told the president that a
special counsel had been appointed the
president slumped back in his chair and
said oh my god
this is terrible this is the end of my
presidency
I'm effed now this is the line that
you're gonna see flying around the
internet a lot of people tweeting this
saying this is not something an innocent
man would say this he was hiding
something he committed a crime what you
have to ask yourself is if that's
evidence that he committed a crime
how come the Special Counsel couldn't
find that he committed a crime if that
line I'm effed if that's evidence the
president Trump committed a crime how
come we had an investigation for two
years they concluded he didn't commit
any crime with the Russian government
during the 2016 election now you might
say what's up what the left would say is
well maybe the crime he committed was
obstruction right okay maybe but he said
this when the special counsel was
appointed this is before obstruction
could have taken place so what is this
actually referring to what the hacks
want you to think is that this is
referring to some action he took during
the campaign
actually Bob Muller himself explains
later in the report what this means says
the president returns to the
consequences of the appointment and said
everyone tells me if you get one of
these independent counsels it ruins your
presidency it takes years and years and
I won't be able to do anything this is
the worst thing that ever happened to me
that's why he's effed that's why it's
the end of his presidency that's why he
reacted that way don't take my word for
it don't take Donald Trump's word for it
take Bob Muller's word for it he puts
that in that same paragraph in the
special council report which the left
doesn't want you to read what he's
pointing out is that once the
Independent Counsel or the special
counsel gets appointed everything
becomes about the special counsel it
stalls all of your plans stalls your
legislative agenda it gets the media
constantly talking against you it drops
your approval numbers it does ruin your
presidency we saw this happen during the
ministration of Bill Clinton that's what
he's pointing to anybody telling you
otherwise is lying now
what about the report there are some
redactions these redactions by the way
are for very limited reasons most of it
is for personal privacy you're not
allowed to release information about
people who were investigated but
ultimately not indicted because that's
obviously not fair to them they were not
indicted they did not have any
accusations in a court of law they
didn't have the opportunity to defend
themselves or to clear their names so
you can't just orbit rarely release what
could be damaging information against
them without giving them the opportunity
to defend themselves the other reasons
are home to ongoing matters this is
another big one that you see throughout
the report so other a lot of these
things are still being investigated so
they can't release information that is
going to damage that okay five sections
here of the report
there's section on the Special Counsel
investigation the investigation itself
there's a section on the social media
campaign that Russia Iran to try to sow
discord in the United States we know a
lot about that we've talked about that a
lot there's a section on Russian hacking
and dumping the Russian government
directing the hacking of the DNC and of
Hillary Clinton and the document dumps
with regard to WikiLeaks then the fourth
section which is on the Russian
government contact with the Trump
campaign and finally on prosecution and
declination decisions only three of
those sections matter to what we're
talking about today we don't care about
the Russia what the Russians did
themselves what we care about is the
investigation we care about any
relations that the Trump campaign had
with Russia and we care about who got
prosecuted and who the Special Counsel
declined to prosecute and we're never
going to agree on anything we're never
going to agree on every single thing but
there is something I think we can all
agree on that we could all use more
sleep how smooth was that how that was
great getting a great night's sleep is
easier and more affordable than you
think you don't need a new expensive
mattress or sleeping pills you just need
to change your sheets that's why you
should check out Boland branch Boland
branch makes everything better blankets
from pure one
percent organic cotton means they start
out super soft they get even softer over
time I had always bought sand paper
sheets basically about the cheapest
thing I could possibly go buy when I was
a bachelor when I got married
bolon branch sent me these sheets they
are the greatest sheets I've ever slept
on I didn't realize it could make a huge
difference it really can and it turns
out I also learned this when I was doing
my wedding registry really nice sheets
can cost up to a thousand dollars in the
store bolon brand sheets there were only
a couple hundred bucks and that's
because they cut out the middleman they
go directly to you everyone who tries
Boleyn branch loves them that's why they
have thousands of five-star reviews even
three u.s. presidents sleep on bowl and
branch sheets shipping is free you can
try them for 30 nights if you don't love
them send them back for a refund I don't
think you're gonna want to send them
back there's no risk no reason to not
give them a try to get started right now
my listeners get $50 off your first set
of sheets at Boleyn branch com promo
code Michael mi CH AE L go to Boleyn
branch comm today $50 off your first set
of sheets Bo LL and branch comm promo
code Michael mi CH AE l Boland branch
comm promo code Michael so that those
are the only really relevant sections of
the Muller report that we care about so
we know the investigation at this point
we've talked about the investigation
itself
ad nauseam Section four Russian
government contact with the Trump
campaign the office identified multiple
contacts links in the words of the
appointment office between Trump
campaign officials and individuals with
ties to the Russian government blah blah
blah blah blah blah blah based on the
available information the investigation
did not establish coordination between
Russia and the Trump campaign in other
words no collusion section 5 this gets
to specifically obstruction here the
office determined that certain
individuals associated with the campaign
lied to investigators about campaign
contacts with Russia and have taken
other actions to interfere with the
investigation so we're now talking about
obstruction of justice the takeaway here
is that people in politics behaved like
people in politics don't let anybody
tell you that everyone behaved
beautifully here nobody did anything
wrong everyone
totally the upright morale thing that's
not what happened
these campaign guys behave like campaign
guys in some cases these guys lied in
some cases in some cases the charges
were totally overblown however that's
not really the point the point is was
there a crime what crime was committed
how was this crime derived uncovered
contrived whatever what does it mean in
the broad scope of Russian interference
here's a good example of this is George
papadopolis campaign official who lied
to investigators he spoke to an
intelligence asset he said he met the
intelligence asset because the guy said
that he had dirt on Hillary Clinton and
George papadopolis said they met with
him before he started working for the
Trump campaign now it turns out he met
with him after he learned he was going
to work with the Trump campaign
investigators asked him about this he
asked him why would why would somebody
approached you with dirt on Hillary
Clinton if you weren't working for the
Trump campaign and George papadopolis
said it was a very strange coincidence
so this is not good lying this is pretty
bad lying it's pretty obvious lying this
raises other questions why did that
asset Joseph Mifsud
approached George papadopolis when he
was already working for the Trump
campaign why did that happen was there
maybe something going on behind the
scenes we don't know about with the
intelligence agencies and the Obama
administration I don't know we're gonna
they're gonna have to be other
investigations to figure that out but it
is the case guys like George papadopolis
did a lie to investigators that's in
there now how about Michael Flint
Michael Flynn made two false statements
he told investigators that he did not
ask the Russian ambassador Sergei gisli
act to refrain from escalating tensions
in response to the US imposition of
sanctions on Russia but he did ask
gisli act to do that who cares who cares
he then apparent the other false
statement he made was he asked the
an ambassador to vote against a
resolution submitted by Egypt to condemn
Israel and he said he didn't ask him to
do that and he did who cares that seems
a lot less fair to get Michael Flynn on
that than George papadopolis George
papadopolis it looks like they got him
pretty much dead to rights
he lied to them they pushed him he lied
some more Michael Flynn it looks like a
setup just to show you the difference
between how different members of the
campaign were treated when we when we
talk about this as a witch-hunt to see
which parts of the witch-hunt which
parts are not obviously what we care
about is president Trump so why didn't
they go after President Trump one Bob
Miller says there are lots of problems
with prosecuting a sitting president and
he says specifically if we had
confidence after a thorough
investigation of the facts that the
president clearly did not commit
obstruction of justice we would so state
based on the facts and the applicable
legal standards however we are unable to
reach that judgment so in other words if
they could totally exonerate the
president of obstruction of justice they
would have they couldn't totally
exonerate him okay that's in there also
they couldn't go after him they couldn't
find any crime that he committed so
accordingly while this report does not
conclude that the president committed a
crime it also does not exonerate him so
what's gonna happen the guys on the Left
are gonna say it does not exonerate him
and the guys on the right are gonna say
it does not conclude that he committed a
crime so let's dig in what did Trump do
what did he actually do he told the
White House Counsel to stop Attorney
General Jeff sessions from recusing
himself he told the White House Counsel
to stop what started the chain events
that led to the Special Counsel
investigation then he complained that
his AG wasn't helping him out and then
he asked sessions to Unruh Cuse himself
we already knew that we already knew
that we saw that play out on Twitter
then when the investigation was
announced President Trump asked the
Director of National Intelligence and
the heads of the CIA and the NSA what
they could do to publicly dispel the
collusion narrative now is that
obstruction
no it's not obstruction because the
collusion narrative was false now if
Trump had actually conspired with the
Russian government and he called his
intelligence agencies and he said go out
there and lie for me that would
certainly be obstruction but in this
case when it sounds like his President
Trump called up the agencies and said
hey you guys know I didn't do this go
out there and tell them I didn't do this
now is that was that proper for him to
do was that professional for him to do
was that presidential for him to do who
cares I don't know I guess maybe it is
maybe it isn't maybe he wasn't as well
practiced as lifelong politicians but
that's not obstruction he also asked
James Comey to lift the cloud of the
Russia investigation after James Comey
said the FBI was not investigating him
personally so same thing add the FBI to
the CIA the NSA in the DNI he all he
just asked James Comey then head of the
FBI hey James Comey you know that I
didn't collude with the Russians can't
you tell people that you're gonna take
out a sitting president for that he then
referred to the appointment of the
special counsel as the end of his
presidency but then Bob Mulder explains
why he did that did that because special
counsels in general disturb presidencies
then he asked sessions to resign
sessions submitted a letter of
resignation he did not accept it at
first then he did again we saw that play
out on Twitter then he told Don McGann
the White House White House Counsel that
special counsel Bob Mulder had conflicts
of interest and he should be removed
this is one that the left is really
focusing on but don McGann the White
House Counsel didn't follow the orders
and then nothing happened so you have
Trump complaining to the White House
Counsel and saying that the special
counsel should be removed don McGann
does not remove the special counsel even
if he had removed the special counsel I
don't think that's grounds even to say
that Trump should be impeached for
obstruction but it didn't happen then he
asked Cory Lewandowski to tell Jeff
Sessions to say the investigation was
unfair to the president of United States
Lewandowski didn't do that because he
didn't want it on the record because he
didn't want to end up in this report
like he ended
anyway then he edited a press statement
for his son Donald Trump jr. to delete a
line that Trump Tower might involve the
Trump Tower meeting the famous Trump
Tower meeting with Russians might
involve information helpful to his
campaign this this one I think is
probably the one that gets closest to
obstruction because he's there kind of
working with his son to work on the
press and present this Trump Tower
meeting is something different but again
there was no Russian conspiracy so
regardless of the Trump Tower meeting
regardless of the emails regardless of
the press statement it amounts to
nothing he then pressured Don McGann the
White House Council to deny media
reports that he asked him to get the
special counsel removed which by the way
the White House Counsel did not do even
if he had I don't think that really
amounts to that much he asked Michael
Flynn's legal team to give him a heads
up on information that implicated him he
praised full mana for it he praised and
then he attacked Michael Cohen we saw
all of this play out on Twitter this is
the big defense if you're obstructing
justice you do it in secret you don't do
it in public can you name one other
example of a president obstructing
justice in public like that I don't
think so
Bob Muller by the way makes this point
in the report he says several features
distinguish this from typical
obstruction cases some of the actions
like firing FBI director James Comey
totally within his authority as
president also there's no underlying
crime also the Twitter of it all they
took place in public view it's going to
be very hard for the left to twist this
report into some awful indictment of the
president it's really what what is the
take away nothing new we know that
President Trump is a real estate
developer from New York we know he
pressures and bullies people like
business executives do we know the be
pressures and bullies people like
he does in public on the campaign trail
even to members of his own
administration we know that there's no
Russian collusion and as this is an
important point as William Bar and
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
point out he is exonerated on
obstruction of justice
Bob Muller submits the report not to the
American people not to Congress not to
the President to the Attorney General
then it is up to the Attorney General
and the Deputy Attorney General to
determine whether or not he is to be
gone after whether or not he's committed
a crime or whether or not there isn't
evidence that he's committed a crime it
is not for the Attorney General to say
well here's the report make up your own
decision no it's up to the Attorney
General to make that decision he and the
Deputy Attorney General both concluded
no obstruction of justice our long
national nightmare is over the Russian
collusion narrative is over the Muller
investigation is over two years for
nothing to find out that Donald Trump is
a tough talk and guy who pressures his
subordinates which we already knew we
got a lot of mail bag to get to I also
have to tell you something folks my
college speaking tour just got ten
schools longer we announced yesterday a
partnership with young America's
Foundation not only are we not going to
cancel the speaking tour because of that
ridiculous leftist assailant at the
University of Missouri Kansas City we
are going to turn it up into high gear
if you would like to have the tour stop
by your school go through the young
America's Foundation put in a request
through them we are going to make
college campuses great again go to Daley
wire comm you know everything you get
you get the leftist ears tumblr you've
never needed it more than today we'll be
right back with the mailbag
ran a little late but one of the bigger
news days of the year so we got to get
through all of that Muller report
especially as we lap up those leftist
tears just as good as I remember them
first question from Mary hey Michael
would you talk about your stance on body
positivity movement the body positivity
movement we see in the media and the
culture yes this is I saw this the other
night there was a student at one of the
schools I spoke at who wore a shirt that
said fat like she was proud that she's
fat and you see all of the body
positivity movements in all its various
forms this is sad because as with
virtually all positivity movements
nobody who says I'm positive I'm
positive I'm positive I'm just so happy
actually is that's always hiding some
amount of shame or discontentment or
negativity now what's the answer to this
the answer to this is not to think less
of yourself the answer is to think of
yourself less obviously it's not healthy
to be really overweight it's not evil to
be really overweight but it's not
healthy so if you can fix it fix it we
all have things about ourselves that we
want to improve that's one aspect of it
I have plenty of things about myself
that I want to improve it doesn't mean
that I hate myself all the time but the
key is think of yourself less it's not
all about you you don't have to be proud
of everything pride goeth before
destruction and a haughty spirit before
a fall only the left could turn the
queen of all sins into the greatest
possible virtue pride you don't need to
be proud of your body you should be
humble you shouldn't hate your body
either you should be humble humble
grateful move on with your life there
are many more interesting things in the
world than your own body weight move on
it's a big world out there go enjoy it
from Antonio hi Michael why do so many X
leftists hesitate to call themselves
conservatives dave rubin and
Jordan Peterson for example thanks
Antonio because they're not
conservatives that's actually the reason
what we're seeing now is not just a
binary between leftists and
conservatives we're seeing another
category which is liberals so I happen
to know Jordan and Dave and I don't
think there are conservatives they've
just invited me on his show so maybe we
can actually talk about this question
but Dave is a liberal he is a classical
liberal he says and in American
political speak we like to say that
classical liberals and conservatives are
the same thing they're not they're not
the same thing
Friedrich Hayek who's a an economic hero
of many conservatives and libertarians
famously wrote an essay where he said
why I'm not a conservative because he's
not he's something a little different
liberals and conservatives are different
what happens in this particular moment
however is that the far left is pushing
things that both liberals and
conservatives disagree with the far left
has turned strongly against freedom
strongly against Liberty so classical
liberals like Dave Rubin who says I I
believe in free speech I believe in the
exchange of ideas they partner up with
conservatives like me who I don't exalt
freedom Liberty some abstract right to
that as though it's the be-all and
end-all of society as though it's the
very end of politics I like tradition I
like veneration I like virtue I like the
good I like prescription I like all of
those things that probably Dave is a
little more skeptical of but the
classical liberals and the conservatives
now are teaming up because we've got
this urgent totalitarian enemy that is
trying to shut down all discourse in the
United States which is the left so I
think it's actually very honest of them
not to call themselves conservatives and
I'm glad that we can have allies in this
battle against censorship and against
relativism and against all of those
pernicious ideologies those destructive
ideologies that are coming from the left
and are going after liberals and
conservatives alike from anonymous hi
Michael
I'm in a really big dilemma with my
future mother-in-law I've been with my
wonderful fiance for almost four years
ever since I met him his mother has had
an issue with me
she makes offhand comments like he won't
love anyone like his mother
we are not hosting a wedding reception
because we're paying for everything when
we told her she flipped out she said
many horrific things to me that I would
never say to anyone she called me the B
word dingdong ding-dong
etc she even mentioned my family in a
nasty way my fiance went upstairs and
started to cry out of respect for him I
kept my mouth shut and took it what
should i do should I just forget it
thank you
no your fiancee should grow a pair
pardon my graphic language are you
kidding me his mother speaks to you like
that gets nasty about your family and he
goes upstairs and cries what's the
matter with him he'll his clearly
there's some weird mommy issue going on
here he'll never love a woman like he
loves his mother or what I mean that
that's sick that is really weird I've
seen these kinds of relationships
sometimes and they're really sick
doesn't mean you have to cut off contact
altogether but you need to make clear
you're the wife you're the most
important woman in his world it's not
even close it's not even like a close
second you need to make that clear and
he needs to man up and accept that and
put his foot down to abandon your
fiancee there well your mother is
yelling profanities and insulting her
family give me a break not only does the
mother-in-law need to apologize I don't
know that she will probably sounds like
she won't your fiance needs to apologize
and then he needs to man up and those
problems are gonna are gonna be a lot
easier to deal with if it's clear who's
the man who's in charge and who the most
important woman in his life is from
Michael Michael you recently smoked
spoke mockingly and derisively of the
value of celebration of life ceremonies
but what about the wishes of the
deceased and those who expressly say
that they want a celebratory event as
opposed to a much more somber church
service do their wishes count for
nothing why do you believe the wishes of
the
event organizers should hold primacy
over those of the deceased thank you
Michael
first of all the wishes of the deceased
don't really count for anything because
they're dead but neither really do the
wishes of the event organizers as you
call them what we're you're really
referring to are the loved ones and the
family of the deceased because we're not
just talking about preferences the whole
conversation about oh I prefer this I
prefer this is actually what got us into
this mess in the first place
when someone dies that's a sad thing
even if they live to be a hundred years
old even if they lived a good life yes
you can take solace that they lived a
good life you can take solace that
they're no longer in pain but you'll
miss them it's sad when they go you
grieve for them this is natural
even Jesus grieves when his friend
Lazarus dies even though he's going to
raise Lazarus from the dead to pretend
that a funeral is some giddy happy
ceremony like the one in that magazine
article where there are hot dog carts
and Jerry Seinfeld is doing comedy sets
it's it's not true it you're you're
trying too hard you're trying to
convince yourself of something that
isn't true and moreover what are you
celebrating because when people have
these celebration of life ceremonies
there aren't funerals in my experience I
know people who have done them and I've
read about others the people who hold
them tend to be atheists they tend to be
irreligious they tend to think that
there's no life after death and when you
die you just turn to worm food and
ultimately there's not a whole lot of
meaning in the world and it's all just
kind of an accident but hey you had a
good time what are you you're not
celebrating anything that's the most
depressing thing I've ever heard and a
funeral which you call somber is is not
a depressing event it's actually
encouraging it's inspiring because we're
sad that we're losing our loved one but
when you have a funeral and you believe
in the resurrection you know that they
are in
a better place you know that they are
seeing their maker face-to-face you have
hope that they're living in everlasting
life that's hope that's a celebration
but you're not going to be able to reach
that joy if you just pretend that
everything is happy happy and death
isn't death and that you're gonna
celebrate something that ultimately you
don't believe has any hope Dante when he
writes the Divine Comedy in order to get
up to heaven in order to see the love
that moves the Sun on the other stars
yes to go down through hell he has to
come out the other side and then ascend
up through purgatory and up to paradise
in our culture we want everything to be
really nice all the time we don't have
to want to deal with any of the
inconvenient tragic facts of life but
mortality is a tragic fact it's not
happy happy joy joy it's a tragic fact
and there happens to be a happy ending
it happens to actually turn out to be a
comedy but it's a comedy it has a happy
ending because of this true hope that
lives within us and that's the hope that
you're going to see in a church looking
at your maker face to face not eating
hot dogs and watching comedian two-asset
at some frivolous celebration of life
from Tom what is the best way for a beta
male to become an alpha male especially
in terms of relationships first step
stop using those terms this terms is so
stupid it's just this issue of if you're
just talking about manliness and alpha
male and masculinity all the time
probably you don't exhibit a whole lot
of it if you got to talk about it if you
got to say it probably you don't exhibit
a whole lot of it how to be a man I
don't know you could go I mean in the
land of the blind the one-eyed man is
king I guess but had to be a man you
first of all should be a gentleman if
you're asking specifically with regards
to relationships and women alpha male
type want to be idiots do this all the
time they try to be really boastful and
they peacock and they try to be big
jerks
that's not how to be a man first tried
the
gentleman a gentleman puts people at
ease that's all a gentleman does so when
you're on a date ask questions and don't
just ask questions be interested in what
she's saying like women love women
that's the first step then be confident
then don't have feel that you have to
prove yourself don't try to work out all
these little tricks
don't try to scheme don't try to get one
over or don't that's very unmanly stuff
there's a good book on this called
manliness by Harvey Mansfield it's it's
worth reading and whenever you hear
people going on to you about Alpha and
Beta and just ignore what they have to
say that's gonna be probably the most
helpful advice on your journey to become
a man good luck son bad speed alright
that's our show so much more to get to
but what can you do you got to read a
400-page report the first thing in the
morning go over to daily wire comm we
have got some more stuff coming up today
but in the meantime have a good weekend
and I will see you on Monday I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael Nolt show
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Rebecca dabka wits and directed by Mike
joiner executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey our
supervising producer is Mathis Glover
and our technical producer is Austin
Stevens edited by Dani D'Amico Audio is
mixed by Dylan case hair and makeup is
by Joshua alvera and our production
assistant is Nick Sheehan the Michael
Noel's show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19
hey guys over on the Matt Walsh show
today the molar report is here it's
finally been released it's the day that
everyone's been waiting for well some
people have been waiting for it anyway
nobody has read the whole thing yet
because it's 448 pages long but why are
we talking about it then what can we say
well I think that there are a few basic
takeaways that we can ascertain already
and they are not takeaways that the left
is necessarily going to like so we'll
talk about that also some other topics
including the fact that Bernie Sanders
the socialist is it turns out pretty
stingy when it comes to his own his own
charitable giving what does that tell us
we'll talk about that and more today
over on the Matt Walsh show